voilà votre à tous cette animalerie
animal expert au centre ville vend
toujours ses chats et ce petit chien
malgré le règlement qu'il interdit
depuis juillet dernier
ces animaux proviennent de fermes
d'élevage et sont vaccinés micro puce et
et inspectés par des vétérinaires comme
l'exigent d'ailleurs le ministère de
l'agriculture des pêcheries et de
l'alimentation
nous on prétend que c'est laid le bois
provincial qui est là la loi sur la
santé la sécurité de l'animal ou le
règlement sur la sécurité et la santé
des chiens des chats qu'ils aient péri
des pierres et priorités
vraisemblablement sur les règlements
nyns selon ce règlement municipal seuls
les animaux provenant de refuge ou de
cliniques vétérinaires peuvent
maintenant être vendus au public
la ville veut ainsi s'assurer du
bien-être des animaux
le règlement est toujours en vigueur
malgré les procédures judiciaires en
cours et la mairesse de montréal entend
le faire appliquer oui un règlement qui
est en place on ne peut pas et on ne
peut pas vendre un peu plus vendre de
d'animaux via les animaleries sur les
territoires de l'est de montréal
et oui les inspecteurs ça fait partie de
leur temps qu'ils ont d'autres pleins
d'autres choses a inspecté mais oui nous
avons l'intention d'appliquer les
règlements mais quelques clients
rencontrés dans cette animalerie ne sont
pas d'accord avec la ville
je sais pas si la mer est reculée c'est
pas le genre à reculer mais moment donné
faut pas aller fo cox et non plus blanc
les gens ont le droit de gagner leurs
hauts faits nous on est allé chercher
dans une place qu'ils avaient pas pu
mieux c'est à dire que les animaux
étaient pas super bien traités je pense
que dans les animaleries en général sont
encore mieux traités que dans ces places
là donc je dirais que je peux tout à
fait d'accord avec ce nom ce que
craignent maintenant les propriétaires
d'animaleries avec cette interdiction de
la ville
et bien c'est une multiplication des
ventes d'animaux en ligne et par
conséquent du retour des usines à chiots
et chatons issigeac bissonnet radio
canada montréal